if you vote for Joe Biden you really are
counting on a president Harris because
the idea that he would make it until 86
years old is not
um is not something that I think is
likely if her concern is Biden won't
live to 86 what does that have to do
with mental competency it's sort of like
a confused thing but this is the most
interesting part of this the numbers
suggest Nikki Haley is wrong there are
what are called Actuarial tables which
tell you at a certain age How likely are
you to die in the following year and
what is your expected uh remaining years
of life if we look at the Social
Security Actuarial tables which are for
men and women statistically if Joe Biden
makes it to 82 and gets elected the
expected outcome is he does live to 86
and finishes the term